[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bonjour le globe
bonjour le monde entier comment il est
si la clé bien moins mais mieux
alors bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
d'on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
aujourd'hui on va voir nico et nico ils
nous proposent des jus frais et tombe
super bien vu la chaleur qui fait
franchement un petit jus qui pourrait
arranger main mais attends jus aloe vera
pas bon train non non non non non des
petits je dis bien en particulier à
l'ailé on va voir nico on va voir nico
parce que la mare soif marc soif il fait
chaud allez venez venez venez bien
vivier g vient pas et pas rapide
[Musique]
comment les nico sapio l'ex la femme ça
va bien être super tipa tipa dis moi où
ça nous laisse à sa le voulait à saint
leu il fait ip hachoud fait vraiment
chaud mais par contre la solution du
mans tout simplement tu es bon endroit
parce qu'on fait des cocktails de fruits
frais glace et voilà que demande le
peuple
il fait chaud et nous nous donne jus de
fruits marmaille on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge chez la meilleure émission et
basta dis moi tu ne montes ça bien sûr
un puissant montanou convaincu tout ça
vous
alors voilà ça c'est le petit dépannage
ici à quand on est un petit peu a cours
au terrain on va récupérer quelques
branches ici la cdc des vieux pieds dans
le verra ça fait déjà quatre ans et donc
là on va choisir un beau pied bien pour
eux par exemple celui là alors on va pas
prendre les va pas prendre les branches
qui sont au sol parce qu'elles servent à
stabiliser la plante en fait d'accord on
va plan à prendre vraiment le la branche
qui se trouve au milieu et on va essayer
de couper vraiment au le plus proche
possible possible du trot voilà nous
fois qu'on sent que là ça va ça va pour
venir on va juste un petit peu aidés
voilà c'est prêt voilà donc là on peut
voir qu'on fait un minimum de dégâts
d'un corps donc ça c'est la base du jus
de fruits qui va nous montrer tout à
l'heure en fait tu m'écoutes un moment
donné ça tout de suite
allez allez c'est parti allons
[Applaudissements]
toiles pinceaux
toi ma chance
ce sont
[Musique]
je
alors donc là c'est là le petit
laboratoire est la voie la cemac ça se
passe alors là j'ai préparé un petit
assortiment de tout ce qu'on peut
retrouver dans nos cocktails d'accord à
savoir bâle à petites feuilles cannelle
cannelle pays racine curcuma voilà donc
là c'est un petit peu la fin de saison
on a trouvé encore un petit peu on à la
menthe fraîche on a le gingembre on à
l'aloe vera l'aloès en mer à l'ouest qui
est une des bases d'une des bases
principales de ce que des jus pouvoir
lancer sa voix la voix la voix parce que
c'est vraiment un produit qu'on a ici
qui pousse bien et puis qu'on a à
profusion et c'est très bon pour la
santé donc nous c'est notre base pour
faire les cocktails quoi en fait cette
plante là elle est vraiment magique
parce que l ai beaucoup de vitamines
beaucoup de minéraux et c'est une plante
donc c'est vivant à la chair même quand
la coupe la plante reste encore vivante
entre donc elle va évoluer même au frigo
elle va développer encore des enzymes et
c'est une plante qu'on peut voilà qui
régénère les cellules enfin que mental
voilà donc c'est ce à quoi les
consommables là dedans fait c'est ça me
fait savoir en fait tout est consommable
tout et consommateurs allemands si la
peau acier consommables mais ça pas là
le même les mêmes vertus
d'abord on va pas l'utiliser pour la
même chose d'accord parce que la normale
à l'ouest c'est vraiment reconnue pour
ses astra gensse a des propriétés
astringentes c'est un petit peu a mais
c'est amer et quand tu manges la peau là
c'est vraiment pour aller aux toilettes
condé à limoges problème si tu en voilà
comment le tamarin c'est vraiment c'est
pour ça qu'on va l'utiliser après la
chaire ça rien à avoir la chair c'est
vraiment nutritifs et voilà c'est ça
qu'on va mettre sur la peau c'est ça
qu'on va manger on va faire des cures
avec la chaire d'accord c'est que -
mimerait bien au fait des démonstrations
des jus parce que tu es tu sais quoi
quand il a soif que les soirs il
n'oublie pas pas et l'oubli moment ils
oublient ils oublient les enfants tu
permets à power un verre d'eau donc
j'imagine privé du train il faut avait
un dieu fois les alors faut faire vite
aller très très vite petit si on aime
bien là le verrons peut prendre tout là
tout le charme ne donne une belle belle
chair bien je la tisseuse ça veut dire
que la planche et la plante elle est
allée richalet vraiment au top de sa
forme
donc il faut parler vraiment assez vite
parce que la loi est la loi s associe
très vite à mettre un petit faut mettre
un petit peu de citron citron pressé
ensuite on va pouvoir rajouter un petit
peu de tisanes de canal va donner un
petit peu le bout
alors après on a le choix on peut mettre
un petit peu de miel là on a un très bon
miel au miel bourbon baies roses
j'aime bien le héros c'est parce qu'il a
un petit peu amer s'amène soit un peu
d'amertume en plus les haltères
voilà
alors l'hibiscus pareil nous mettrons
grammes par litre mais y'en a qui vont
aimer c'est ça c'est un petit peu assez
du rna km moineau qui nous est plus ça
c'est vraiment une question de goût on
va voir la belle couleur de l'hibiscus
on va quand même être un petit peu de
gingembre
parce que le jeune homme ça moi je peux
pas m'empêcher de mettre toujours un
petit morceau si on a sous la main un
petit peu de menton tu peux demander
monde poivrer j'aime bien la menthe
poivrée
voilà mes tendances et un petit morceau
le curcuma voilà que voilà ma vie voilà
que tu as payé là il transpire ça c'est
la petite douceur
c'est la menace pour la broméline
surtout digestion encore une fois et on
rajoute père va rajouter ça vous allez
voir qu'on aura déjà un beau petit
équilibre
[Musique]
alors on va se mettre ici on va faire un
joli quittâmes comme ça va un impeccable
maintenant à l'honneur soit réticente ça
tu sais vraiment rien avec la couleur
j'ai envie de boire ce soir c'est en
vous je mets ça tire à peu vers l'orangé
avec ses ceintures que moi ces volcans
quoi c'est 100% la réunion marmaille la
volcan bol qu'on vire sur explosif
alors là le vrac c'est bien homogénéiser
on sent bon en plus à la tienne sainté
gramoune sortait gramounes
ah ouais c'est quand même fou parce qu
on vous sent alors demi sans safran dans
le corps humain mais sans le citron mais
sans la cannelle fracas des lots à canal
pro l'ananas et un peu aussi ouais à la
nage et nous dit monsieur tu vois là là
là c'est vraiment le petit la
gourmandise non merci je n'ai pas eu de
sinko c'est un petit verre mais après je
suis quand même assez délicieux c'est
délicieux maman je dis chapeau
vraiment on va pouvoir peut-être aller
en bois sur la plage sur la plage tu
veux dire qu'on va descendre un docteur
sur la place rabin écoute moi ça me
ferait plaisir de te faire goûter un peu
ce qu'on propose sur les plages en dix
mois face à la plage tu vas te baigner
tu vas pas te baigner tu n'as pas
emmener ton maillot de bain tant pis
pour toi petit jeu
[Musique]
mon
après quatre heures de marche harassante
sous le soleil de plomb nous voilà à
l'ermitage et à l'âme et agents fin de
compte va retrouver unique aux aînés
cours on va le suivre avec son petit bar
ambulant tranquille toujours dans les
jus de fruits aloe vera d'accord et
arrêtez de me faire marcher comme ça un
moment donné je vous aime d'accord mais
amazon mais à un moment donné ne peut
pas un député le cratère la terre la
planète eau mais ils sont là il a fait
son chemin saint louis
bonjour bonjour enchanté jean claude
dumont un petit peu donc cette petite
machine c'est toi qui l'a fabriqué c'est
ça ensemble à samia comprends pas moi
tout seul mais da conduire à plusieurs
dalles en fait est là en fait avec ce
petit ses petits ces petites roulettes
ambulante là où peut vendre des jus de
fruits à présent son droit comme ça tu
peux te déplacer trop craindre
exactement la cour qui va bien voilà
lavagna bas pour aller à faire un petit
truc pour les laver
voilà tout ce qu'il faut voilà tout ce
qu'il faut dis moi on va rentrer dans
des choses sérieuses nico je suis
extrêmement curieux mon grand-père la
diamant alex ou trop curieux tu es prêt
pour la série de questions allez vas-y
dix mois déjà comment tu en es arrivé
avant des jus de fruits naturels à base
d'aloe vera est ce que tu es au lycée tu
te disais moi un jour je serai vont des
fruits depuis tout petit depuis qu'il a
6 ans c'est ça mister aloe vera sérieuse
il dit moi tout non non pas du tout pas
du tout en fait
moi je viens du milieu de la viticulture
d'accord donc le travail la vinification
tout ça donc j'ai quand même petite
notion avec les goûts et les équilibres
qu'on peut avoir en bouche
mais après je connaissais rien du tout
aux vertus des plantes
le petit âne heures tous aller les
herboristes je connaissais pas d'accord
donc c'était nouveau pour moi je me suis
réformer tout seul un peu lent et tous
les jours jarre on apprend de toute
façon d'accord mais l'idée même l'idée
serait de se dire tiens il ya de l'aloe
vera ya des fruits je vais mixer les
deux est ce que tu as vu ça ailleurs est
ce que oui j'ai vu ba beaucoup dans les
voyages parce que nous étions voyage
comme un petit peu avec le surf ou qu on
est délinquant de surfer aussi à tout le
monde
ben voilà ça fait partie le sport le
bien-être du coup ça va ensemble et moi
même pour moi j'aimais bien après le
sport avoir un bon petit coup de frais
redynamiser un petit peu le corps on a
besoin et l'aloe vera pour ça je trouve
c'était vraiment l'idéal parce que non
seulement on peut l'inclure jt on peut
la voir mais en plus on peut se la
passer sur la peau après le soleil se
régénère la peau est très bon pour la
rive pour les cheveux et que c'est un
produit fantastique pour ça ben écoute
maman etc a besoin de bonnes affaires
vous connaissez venir d'accord alors moi
je suis pas triste 1 c'est juste qu'il
ya beaucoup de soleil d'accord écoute
médias où on va voir les prochaines
bonne continuation merci beaucoup
et bravo encore bravo encore de m
merci d'être passé voir d'autres où
aller et oui messieurs dames
on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge c'est
fini toutes les bonnes choses ont une
fin
c'est comme ça c'est la vie mais promis
je reviendrai vous voir
alors je mens vers le coeur léger après
un petit jus de fruits bien corsé bien
vitaminé avec l'aloe vera et au fait
très important dans la vie très très
important on n'est vraiment pas sorti de
l'auberge
moi qui disent vote enfin c'est que vous
ayez vu si j'ai vues croisées croit à
ses yeux pas recroiser crois pas le même
vieux zot
on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge mais pas
du tout mais vraiment on n'est pas sorti
de l'auberge quoi
parce que franchement
faire partie
[Musique]